Speaker 1: So, OK, we already talked about
mostly Democrats, but not all.
Democrats, combined with a few Republicans
in the House, came together.
They passed a much smaller than initially
proposed bipartisan infrastructure bill.
Good.
Some Republican House members broke with Republican
Party leadership like Kevin McCarthy, who
were saying Don't help Democrats pass the
bill.
They weren't making an argument about the
necessity of the bill.
They weren't making an argument about anything
other than don't help Democrats pass the bill.
Trump Republicans are absolutely furious with
those few Republicans that voted for the infrastructure
bill in the House, and they are now vowing
to remove the Republicans from the House.
Quite frankly, this is great.
Democrats are not very competent.
We have a competence problem, and certainly
I can speak to the United States.
If you've been watching the Kyle Rittenhouse
trial with us, you very quickly see there's
just a lot of incompetence in general in the
general public.
And that means a lot of Democrats aren't competent
and that applies to the Democratic Party.
Last week's election results looked terrible
for Democrats heading into 2022.
The biggest gift that Republicans can hand
to Democrats is that they fight among themselves.
13 House Republicans crossed party lines and
they voted in favor of the bipartisan infrastructure
bill.
Six Democrats also crossed party lines and
voted against the bill, and Republicans are
going nuts over those 13 Republicans.
Florida Republican Congressman Anthony Sabatini
tweeted quote every Republican who voted for
the infrastructure bill must be eliminated
from the party.
Colorado Representative Lauren Boebert may
be one of the worst people currently involved
in American politics.
Quote rhinos, meaning Republicans in name
only just pass this wasteful $1.2 trillion
infrastructure bill.
But Pelosi did not have the votes in her party
to pass this garbage time to name names and
hold these fake Republicans accountable.
North Carolina Congressman Madison Cawthorn
tweeting quote Vote for this infrastructure
bill and I will primary the hell out of you.
Josh Barnett, who calls himself an America
first candidate for the Arizona House, tweeted
13 Republicans just voted to turn America
into a communist country.
They should be pushed back on so hard till
2022 that their lives are miserable until
we have them removed, by the way.
Building a bridge is not communist.
Fixing roads isn't communist.
Saying, Hey, if we want people to buy electric
cars, how about chargers for the electric
cars?
That's not communist.
And in fact, all of those things support private
industry in reality.
Matt Gates also jumping on the bogus socialism
fear mongering, tweeting, I can't believe
Republicans just gave the Democrats their
socialism bill.
Not only is the bill not communism, the bill
is also not socialism, but lots of his followers
believe it.
There has been this idea historically in the
Republican Party.
They love calling themselves the big tent
party.
We welcome all sorts of views.
We welcome this type of conservative and that
type, you know, OK, as long as you vote for
Republic.
Guns are not for Democrats, is voting with
Democrats sort of the same as voting for Democrats
in the minds of these Trump Republicans, I
say, let them fight, encourage it, actually.
It can only be good for the left.
I would rather Democrats be more competent
and and win elections more regularly by being
competent.
I'm very worried that that's not the case
going into 2022, and so I will take any help
that the Left can get.
And Republicans fighting among themselves
is a good thing in terms of helping the left
now at the same time.
The stupidity of infrastructure bills are
communist and socialist.
That's something else.
And I wonder if you went to these folks and
you said, Do you do you understand?
Do you know about the military taxpayer funded
socialism with mandatory vaccines to boot?
But that's different.
Of course, these are folks who at the end
of the day, they want King Emperor Trump.
And reality doesn't really make a difference
to them.
They don't even know the things they want
to destroy, but they know they want to destroy
a lot of them in government, remember?
I was reminded of just such a classic political
moment when former Texas Governor Rick Perry
ran for the Republican presidential nomination.
He had a bunch of departments he wanted to
remove.
Couldn't remember exactly what they were.
But he definitely wants to remove them.
Remember this insane moment?
Speaker 2: And I will tell you it's three
agencies of government when I get there that
are gone commerce, education and the what's
the third one there?
Let's see.
Oh, five.
OK, so commerce, education and the EPA?
EPA There you
Unidentified: go.
No, again, let's stop.
Let's stop.
Seriously.
Speaker 2: Is EPA the one we're talking about
here?
No, sir.
No, sir, we were talking about the agencies
of government.
EPA needs to be rebuilt, but you care about,
but you can't name the third one, the third
agency of government.
I would I would do away with education, the
commerce, the commerce.
And let's see, I can't.
The third one, I can't.
Sorry.
Speaker 1: Oops.
So anyway, they definitely wanted destroy
a lot of this stuff the government is doing,
and sometimes they don't even remember all
of it.
But now building roads and bridges is is yet
another thing.
I guess they don't want the government to
be involved in.
So my message is absolutely get these Republicans
out.
Challenge them.
Primary them.
Do all of it because the left needs help,
guys after last week.
It's looking very ugly.
Now, some of you wrote to me and said, David,
you're exaggerating, it's not looking that
ugly in 2022.
Yes, it is.
And even if we're not sure it's looking that
ugly, do we really want to take any chances?
My view is no.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
Our program, the David Pakman Show, does really
depend on the support of our podcast, listeners
of our YouTube viewers of folks who listen
on the radio or watch on TV or on free speech
TV.
We have something called the membership program.
You can sign up on my website.
Join Packman VK.com.
We do a whole bunch of extra content for our
paid members to show our appreciation, including
another show every single day.
So you've got the broadcast show, the podcast,
and then we do another show called The Bonus
Show for our paid subscribers.
I would love it if you signed up.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
Also, you get commercial free audio feeds
and video feeds of the show.
So if you want to watch the entire thing with
no commercials, you can do it as a member
if you want to listen to the entire thing
with no commercials.
You can do it as a member.
We also have a discount code.
That code is better 21, and you can use it
if you would like